the magnitude of devastation is hard to
take in
but shows the power of storm eunice
a 400 year old tree ripped from its root
destroying this family home in essex in
seconds i was in a conference call in
that room sven good was working
downstairs when the tree hit i heard
this gigantic creek and then a huge bang
and the whole house shook and i sort of
jumped i'm sorry guys i've got to get
off
i ran to see if my girlfriend was okay
who she didn't even know that the house
had gone down
and then me and my mom both ran upstairs
and checked out my room which now has no
wall went to see my sister's room and
that's just a scene of chaos really this
is the view inside that bedroom it will
be a long wait to fully assess the
damage but it could have been a lot
worse this was a very lucky escape for
this family who've lived here in this
house for generations and like many up
and down the country they now face a
huge cleanup operation and are hoping
that the weather doesn't hamper their
efforts
work will soon begin in southampton to
return this roof to its rightful owner
a block of flats down the road
on this london street the strong winds
turned a roof into rubble and a
children's playground into a danger zone
the iconic o2 arena will remain closed
so staff can make it safe after winds
tore through its roof
there's also been a second day of severe
travel disruption with snow grinding
roads to a halt in the north and trains
cancelled as trees and debris are taken
off the tracks
trains are in the wrong locations
there's still
debris being removed from our roads
airports are expected to be very busy
people catching up with flights
and potentially queues of ports
a busy and confusing time for some
people waiting to get home our train was
booked at 10 o'clock but it's been
delayed and we've
we've just heard there might be one
going in a minute
fingers crossed i managed to get my
ticket refunded but in terms of actually
getting home i'm not really sure and
then i turned up a paddington to get my
connection to the bath and completely
closed no trains at all
so i stayed the night with my family in
london
came back and now bart's not even on the
thing so i'm going to ask them now
storm eunice was one of the worst to hit
the uk in decades it's going to take
time to clear the widespread destruction
left in its wake charlotte lomas sky
news